see a car
this is my car
how about that get your car apart
my car
so you're gonna damage your own property
I paid for this car [ __ ]
tell him I'll break the windows next
Angela is getting her Jasmine Sullivan
on
[Music]
as she takes apart Michael's car all
because he won't come to the door when
she randomly pops up on him in Nigeria
he's scared I would be too you never
know what to expect with Angela and
remember all of this started because he
wouldn't take down his Instagram
his Instagram and yes he did ask Angela
for five thousand dollars if she wants
him to deactivate his account which
scream scammer alert
scammer alert to me but I'll be honest
after this episode I'm having second
thoughts Michael reveals why he got back
on social media in the first place after
Angela told him not to no she told me
she's gonna take care of me but for the
past some months now she hasn't sent me
enough money I need to know
make extra money for myself I'll become
an influencer Yes Y'all Michael is out
here trying to make money as an
influencer
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia they
keep teasing us with this Michael and
Angela fight just show it come on now
but before we get into the minutes
leading up to Michael exploding on
Angela
all right stay away I want to chat with
you about the latest on shaida and Bilal
I haven't applied man with Dr mirabili
Shai received some concerning news after
she and Below went to a fertility clinic
to find out what her chances are for
getting pregnant well I should say shot
it took Bilal to the fertility clinic
because he did not want to be there
is a thousand percent strange to me that
we're at a fertility clinic and we
haven't even started trying as we know
shy is 37 and she really wants to work
on having a baby now
Bilal wants to wait a few years before
they try he's leaning on the fact that
the prenup says they will attempt to
have a baby before she's 40. we uh zero
when it comes to trying okay
he doesn't want to like try right now
there's a lot right now that's happening
I mean you just came to a whole new
country we just got married there's a
lot of Firsts a lot of new stuff and a
lot of women go through postpartum
and I don't want you to worrying about
that right now so it's better for her to
worry about a high risk pregnancy she'd
already be considered a geriatric
pregnancy at this point and the older
she gets the higher the risk for her and
the baby when it comes to these two I
don't think there is a perfect time I
just don't want if we do you know see
right now like that she would take
because it happens to be honest with you
but I love everybody take take the
aggression of all the things she didn't
want to do like her business I'm heavily
involved trying to help her and
establish that because like to take
those things out on me because you know
things change or body change and you
know and now we have a child that's also
expecting the worst soup allowed I could
juggle all those things I'm just I mean
I'll be a super mom postpartum is real
below keeps bringing up postpartum but I
think it's also important to acknowledge
that she can experience postpartum when
she gets pregnant later and who's to say
that her experience with it now would be
worse than two years from now
life happens
and on top of that she might not even go
through it the reality is that this is a
risk every woman takes when they get
pregnant and regardless wouldn't this
ultimately be up for her to decide yeah
he might have to deal with the side
effects but she would be the one going
through it you know it might sound a
little juvenile but maybe you'll get a
piece of paper put the pros and the cons
together and make the decision about
doing this right the doctor said I'm not
a therapist so let's get into what I can
help you with I've never been pregnant
before you've never been pregnant before
he asked shaida about her medical
history and she reveals a very important
piece of information that concerns him
how are your Cycles I have a regular
monthly cycle which is good like every
21 days my period comes on time as you
see
coming 21 days or 28 days 21 41 yeah
okay so a little bit brief with that
because the typical cycle is about 26 to
30 days yeah so if we're ovulating it's
really a short time period
what do y'all think Bilal is thinking
right now and I want to check some blood
work on you too thyroid a couple hormone
levels and see whether your eggs are
healthy and ready to be impregnated and
see if there's something going on there
oh that's scary to hear
this is a vulnerable Journey Shada is
going on in front of all of us
being real
21 day cycle doesn't cut it as far as
ovulation and getting pregnant day 14
you would ovulate and an egg is
available for sperm to fertilize if it's
not there we're not going to get a
pregnancy is something going on with her
that we need to test further
I think you know emotionally together
you know you guys you know make a
decision like are we going to do you
know the weight the two years and go
through the ups and downs of just
getting married and everything or is it
something that we need to say hey you
know what your risk increase as you get
older shadow lets the doctor know that
that is her main fear meanwhile this is
bilal's response any other
questions or concerns about that
sounds like you're saying it's probably
best to wait a couple of years
wrong answer that is not what he said
are we gonna do you know the wait the
two years and go through the ups and
downs of just getting married and
everything or is it something that we
need to say hey you know what your risk
increase as you get older any other
questions or concerns about that
sounds like you're saying it's probably
best to wait a couple of years
[Music]
down this is
you don't want to bring a baby into the
world that you're not ready for
but you know there are risks as a woman
gets older if it's something you really
need to sit down and talk about that and
make that decision earlier in the
episode Shadow was having a conversation
with her friend back in Trinidad and the
friend told her that there is a chance
Bilal could be leading her on with no
real intention to have a baby with her
now
that would be Beyond messed up that's
evil I am hoping that that is not the
case here but Shadow says if below does
not stand by his word
she's taking him to court
as she should I wanted a traditional
marriage he decided to get all
contractual on me so this is the price
of contracts you pay
speaking of pay let's move on to Michael
who's trying to make money as an
Instagram influencer and Angela whose
jealousy is getting in the way of his
hustle well she has been giving me a
very very tough time now
no she told me she's gonna take care of
me but for the past some months now she
hasn't sent me enough money why not just
made me get a job
well when I started my Visa process she
told me not to not to walk stay at home
till my Visa comes out Michael tells us
Instagram because she thinks he's
flirting with women I'm not taking it
down meanwhile according to him he's
just looking for ways to make some money
I need to you know make extra money for
myself so I'm bringing back my my social
media and uh becoming an influencer and
I will be making more more money
or have you made money since when you've
been on social media that's question
I mean I'm getting the the audience now
Angela is selling stuff on her Instagram
why can't I this is a new beginning
so that's why I had to do what makes me
happy you know this is what we've really
been we really wanted all along well
fast forward to now Michael's Instagram
dreams have yet to come true based off
my research his Instagram is deactivated
I don't know if Angela ended up paying
him the money or if he just felt weak
and gave in but yeah at this moment
Michael doesn't have an account I still
love my wife and I want to keep my
marriage going but it's important for me
to make my opinion count in the marriage
listen to me no no just forget about it
let me just say this if Michael is
scamming Angela he gets the 90 Day
Fiance best actor award I mean seriously
ropes of pearls says quote I don't think
Michael scammed Angela I think Angela
picked a weak man to control as she
likes I'm happy to see Michael finally
standing up for himself
when it comes to my honest opinion after
this episode
I'm in the middle I for sure think that
one of the reasons why Michael is in
this relationship with Angela is to get
to America for sure but I also think he
fell in love with her and before the
surgeries he was attracted to her look
at these moments after they first got
engaged a few years back I just landed
in Lagos Nigeria to reunite with my
fiance Michael and I'm excited at some
point during this trip things will get
more serious I miss my baby y'all got to
go
see they have the chemistry you can't
deny that huh moving on
[Music]
after Michael told Angela to pay him 5K
to take his Instagram down she lands in
Nigeria without him knowing just so she
can make sure he's not scamming her
before his Visa comes through which
would allow him to come to America
immediately cheer cheers
[Music]
Nigeria baby
and if you're wondering who this woman
is this is Renee she and Angela met
smoking a cigarette in an airport
bathroom a while back and now they're
friends interesting she decided to join
Angelo on this trip for emotional
support now fast forward to the night
after they land I was gonna wait to see
Michael tomorrow surprise him I told him
to take it on Instagram give him another
chance do it on his own and he responded
with laughing emoji saying laugh out
loud she and Renee prepare for a night
mission
you're not calling him are you
[Music]
are you awake
are you awake answer yes or no
stay away
you're getting ready to get that
shocking y'all all right stay awake
I'm gonna show you I ain't playing with
you no more see one thing you don't know
about me Michael you can't manipulate a
woman that's strong and been strong of
her life whatever [ __ ]
she has to get that quick [ __ ] and
before she hung up
come on Angela you can't speak to people
like that and expect for them to do
right by you
not climbing over the gate
hello
she was about to walk up in that house
hello
Renee just found out how Wild her new
friend can be
that's my car by the way Renee yeah you
see that car I'm a Nigerian Woman
married she's a Nigerian Woman married
Michael come out
he's scared
Michael why don't you just come out she
just wants to talk come out
are you kidding me I love you but you
will not take me for granted she really
doesn't see that she's the one in the
wrong right now
she popped up at this man's house
unannounced she popped up in Nigeria
unannounced now she's banging on his
door late at night not even considering
that there may be others in there who
are asleep
you don't respect my family I don't
respect nobody put your feet in my shoes
would you like it if someone didn't
protect you that you married and put
your whole life ahead that you're
getting older you're going to die
earlier than this man and he's got his
whole life ahead of him you put your
life on pause
[Music]
tell Michael answer them
he called him stupid Michael
[Music]
hey what that's all right we'll just
tell
car see a car
this is my car
I'm out how about that
my car Michael come on Michael
I paid for this car [ __ ]
tell him I'll break the windows next you
got the wrong mother
[Music]
Angela has to stop blaming Michael and
start looking at her actions period next
week Michael does come out and he goes
off on Angela in a way that we have
never seen before
telling me
I trusted you ever since I signed I do
this man everything went down here you
will not come on Visa
Michael is furious and poor guy in the
orange he probably woke up to this mess
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time